David: And yeah, now that it's recording I'd like to confirm, are you comfortable if I record my screen and the audio as we talk today.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yes, that's fine.
David: Fantastic.
David: Okay, so now let's just jump into it.
David: could you tell me a little bit about your role at the Va.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I am there. The Jamesy Van Zant, sharepoint mot or administrator and website, administrator and secondary, graphic artist.
David: Got it got it? And how often are you uploading photos or images to the Cms.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Fair or not very often. We've always been under the impression that the fewer imagery uploaded the better.
David: Okay, yeah. Could you tell me more about that?
VHAALTLEMKEC: When I took over working, and we transferred from team site to drupal.
VHAALTLEMKEC: We were told that the system is laid out the way it is.
VHAALTLEMKEC: There's very specific things that we are allowed to change.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and it should be kept as uncluttered and predominantly. Text
VHAALTLEMKEC: laden or text
VHAALTLEMKEC: centric is the better word I want.
David: Heccentric
David: gotcha. When you do upload images, what are you ever uploading images for?
VHAALTLEMKEC: Every so often I'll upload images for news stories.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Events.
VHAALTLEMKEC: sometimes press or press release
VHAALTLEMKEC: or minor page images so like a little low, or one of the Va Logos, or something like that.
David: Gotcha and
David: Could you describe your general workflow when you're uploading an image?
David: Like, for example, where you get the images from? Are you doing any editing that kind of thing?
VHAALTLEMKEC: Any of the any of the images I upload usually come from the if if they're logo designs for the Va, they're from the tier one site.
VHAALTLEMKEC: the sharepoint site that we have.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I know how the Va is on, you know, Logos, and everyone making up their own little designs. I gotta keep stopping my teams over here from creating things it's like, no, you can't do that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Photos and stuff like that are taken from our our public Affairs department and a lot of times I'll just be editing for dead space and color corrections.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And sometimes we'll upload graphics of flyers and things like that that can be
VHAALTLEMKEC: downloaded as a Pdf or a
VHAALTLEMKEC: Png file. So.
David: So, yeah, just a couple of things there.
David: 1st question on. That is
David: what what
David: you said. You get rid of white space or things like that. What tools do you typically use? Photoshop
David: Photoshop? Okay? And about how often, how how much time do you spend?
David: Kind of.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I'm on. I'm on Photoshop on average.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, 30 HA week.
David: 30 HA week. Okay?
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, I'm a i'm my primary is
VHAALTLEMKEC: the sharepoint development where I do a lot more graphics there, because we're a little bit more leeway there.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and secondary I do graphic arts for my
VHAALTLEMKEC: Public Affairs office. So I do. Flyers, posters, things like that. So I'm I'm always working in in Photoshop.
David: Gotcha. Okay?
David: And it's
David: so one thing that I'm I'm pretty familiar with with
David: uploading things like events or stories is that there's always specific ratios that are required
David: when you're bringing photos into those
David: like. When you're creating pages or things with those, do you ever use the cropping tools and things that are.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yes, I know.
David: Calls, or like.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Do.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, in. I do use the cropping tools in both drupal
VHAALTLEMKEC: and in our system. What I would prefer this is just me. I would prefer actual measurements, as in instead of ratio sizing
VHAALTLEMKEC: cause like a 7 to one ratio to me is just.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I'm like, I gotta really think that through, instead of saying, You know x by y.
David: Got it. So my, maybe I more ideally
David: and I. I'm just saying this because I have a little graphic background. But you correct me if I'm wrong.
David: So it'd be like you'd want
David: to see 1750 by 500
David: to me.
David: Make your template in like
David: Photoshop that right? Something like that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Exactly. Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah. I mean, I know the 7 to one ratio is.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, 7 pixels to one pixel.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But it's like, still, that's more math than my brain wants to deal with.
David: So, having kind of like an ideal ratio
David: would be helpful for you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yes.
David: And where would that?
David: Oh, go ahead!
VHAALTLEMKEC: You know. When you upload the image, you know, and it gives you the rate it gives you the ratio listing and the crop or like. When you upload for events.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, you'll upload the file, and it'll say this, you know, this is limited to a 7 by
VHAALTLEMKEC: one, or ratio, or something by 2. Ratio.
David: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It would be great if it would say, like 7 by 2 ratio or 3, you know, 1,800 by 600 pixels, you know, or something like that. Just the addition.
David: We edition, and the combination would be helpful for you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That would be awesome.
David: Okay, that's fantastic to hear. My other question for you is you mentioned uploading Pdfs and things like that? Flyers?
David: Where do you find yourself most often uploading those.
David: What? What content? Types.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Detail pages.
David: Detail pages.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And there's another thing, because I just did a page for that for our women's, health organis or woman's health department.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and they had like.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I think it was 15
VHAALTLEMKEC: or 18 Pdfs. They wanted to upload.
VHAALTLEMKEC: You know. It's it's all good information that's very useful, and it's, you know, good place for it to be, you know, one spot.
VHAALTLEMKEC: but we're limited to a
VHAALTLEMKEC: straight in line
VHAALTLEMKEC: list of those documents.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It would be nice if there was an ability to
VHAALTLEMKEC: like tile them
VHAALTLEMKEC: tired of.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah. Cause when you
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, 18 documents will take up.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, a good
VHAALTLEMKEC: half scroll or something, whereas if I was able to tile it straight across, it wouldn't take up.
VHAALTLEMKEC: You wouldn't have to scroll like 3 times to get to the bottom if that makes sense.
David: Yeah, yeah, you'd rather, instead of going all the whole list down, you could really organize it in a way that would work for you, and I'm curious with events and things like that. Do you find yourself ever
David: taking flyer bits? And and are you cause? Because for events right, you'll get like a flyer or something, and like there's like a ha! Do you translate those to that banner size? Are you finding another way to upload them. How? How do you kind of decide what to do with those.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I I usually
VHAALTLEMKEC: I'll usually take the design that we've come up with for the flyer or poster
VHAALTLEMKEC: and compress and redesign to match that banner size and then use the the text box that's provided with the the events
VHAALTLEMKEC: posting to add the text information that would be found on the flyer.
David: Got it? And how do you kind of balance
David: text and an image with accessibility? How do you find yourself doing that?
VHAALTLEMKEC: That's that's 1 of the hard ones. Accessibility
VHAALTLEMKEC: is a big thing around here, especially we have a couple of visually impaired
VHAALTLEMKEC: veterans that really use our website. So
VHAALTLEMKEC: I just, I just try to make sure that whenever I'm putting in the Alt texts for the images
VHAALTLEMKEC: I try to make. I mean, if it's if it's a text image, you know, it's like
VHAALTLEMKEC: enrollment fair.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know. I will actually describe the imagery and then put in the text enrollment, fare with it.
David: So.
VHAALTLEMKEC: You know.
VHAALTLEMKEC: blue gray background with us, you know, with an American flag overlaid with the text enrollment fair. Something like that.
David: Over overlay with the text enrollment fair. Yeah.
David: Got it?
David: Okay. So I'd like to jump into our 1st task. I, if if you could
David: log into drupal and share with me how you kind of upload an image to an event.
David: I think that would be a really great place to start.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, I'm just a heartbeat.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Nothing important.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay.
VHAALTLEMKEC: okay, let me get to.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, that's Monday. Okay, every so often we get those notices like technical problem, wait, what.
David: Oh no!
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And
VHAALTLEMKEC: okay. So let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I don't usually use
VHAALTLEMKEC: zoom. So how do we share the imagery?
David: Oh, yeah, there's like a green share button.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Sure, I see it down here at the bottom. Okay, screen 2
VHAALTLEMKEC: and share.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay, can you see me? Okay, yeah.
David: Yep.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay, perfect. So, for example, if we were gonna do an event
VHAALTLEMKEC: content, events.
David: Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Give it a second to catch up.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and I love that it spell checks me.
David: Yeah, that's so helpful.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Alright. So whatever day
VHAALTLEMKEC: event image.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So I've already got a few of these. So like we did the drive through clinic shot.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But basically, all I do is I select the file
VHAALTLEMKEC: provided it opens anything up there we go.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: let's go with that best.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So open.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Then I would put the description in here.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Not not gonna write it right now. But
VHAALTLEMKEC: there we go. Here's where.
David: What kind of description would you put in there? You don't have to write it, but you can just.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, most of the time I would put in for a description. It would be
VHAALTLEMKEC: graphic, graphic.
VHAALTLEMKEC: graphic title for Vetfest summer, 2024.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And then for the alternative text for this one, it would be something along the line of
VHAALTLEMKEC: illustration of dog tag with gold star
VHAALTLEMKEC: overlaid text. Summer 2024 vet. Fest.
David: Got it. So they're just what's what would you use to mark the difference between description and all text if you had to describe it to a new editor.
VHAALTLEMKEC: To be honest for me. There isn't that much of a difference.
VHAALTLEMKEC: except that in this case the description is what shows up in the media library.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Whereas the alternate text isn't what shows up in the media library.
David: Now, do you often find yourself looking for images in that media library?
VHAALTLEMKEC: No, I almost never use it.
David: You almost never.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Except to find my own pictures that I've uploaded before.
David: Got it. So you're interested in the pictures you've uploaded? Are you ever using pictures? Anyone else has uploaded.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I've kind of looked through them. I just haven't most of the time when I'm uploading images. It's very specific to our facility
VHAALTLEMKEC: and the stories that we're posting. So most of the photos out there, unless I need like
VHAALTLEMKEC: a graphic of
VHAALTLEMKEC: oh, one of the Va, you know, tier one Logos. Someone's already uploaded it, you know. Usually you can find those pretty quick.
David: Got it.
David: Okay, great and then.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But here's where we run into the this is where I would like to see the.
David: Yeah, before we get to that. If you scroll up just a bit.
David: could we go through the section?
VHAALTLEMKEC: So select section who will manage this.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I always take it down to
VHAALTLEMKEC: vision for Altoona va altoona health care cause. That's me.
David: That's you.
David: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And.
David: Yep, yeah. You already told us what you'd input it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So we just put that. And then
VHAALTLEMKEC: the since this is a 7 2,
VHAALTLEMKEC: this is where I would like to see. I'd like to see the great, the numbers, because I can go back into the Graphic
VHAALTLEMKEC: in Photoshop and re-edit it to match.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because I can't get this. You won't be able to get this square into this square. You know what I mean.
David: Hmm!
David: And what would happen if you picked the 2 by 3, for example.
David: or 3 by.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Let me see which. 1, 3 by 2. Nope.
VHAALTLEMKEC: usually go with original.
David: You normally go through. Okay.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But because you go with the original.
VHAALTLEMKEC: do a save and insert
VHAALTLEMKEC: it's still not going to.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It won't cut. When you
VHAALTLEMKEC: publish the event.
VHAALTLEMKEC: it's still gonna be cut off.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It's still gonna do.
David: The 7 by 2.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because it's limited to a 7 by 2 exactly.
David: Okay? And has that happened to you before.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yes, so I've just gone in, edited the event
VHAALTLEMKEC: and
VHAALTLEMKEC: redesign the the banner piece.
David: Okay. But there was a point once where you
David: uploaded an image you selected like original or or 2 by 3, 3 by 2, and then uploaded it. You thought it was going to be good.
David: and then.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It wasn't.
David: When do you find out? It wasn't what happened like, how do you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Winner.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Well, usually, when you get to the publish setting.
David: Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Have you have to
VHAALTLEMKEC: let me go ahead and
VHAALTLEMKEC: teaser
VHAALTLEMKEC: don't need that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Nope out of the a
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And so we'll go to published
VHAALTLEMKEC: now you have to save. Oh, Crud.
VHAALTLEMKEC: let's go with today
VHAALTLEMKEC: at
VHAALTLEMKEC: 5
VHAALTLEMKEC: and 6
VHAALTLEMKEC: a at
VHAALTLEMKEC: 7.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That's
VHAALTLEMKEC: alright. So let's do it.
David: Yeah. Cool.
David: Sorry.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Like the value. That's okay.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, I'll tune up.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I'm doing Erie, Chicago.
VHAALTLEMKEC: There we are.
VHAALTLEMKEC: everything. Oh, go ahead.
David: I'm just curious. Were you trying to type it in
David: just now? I've been.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, I just I went to hit Altuna. I type Altoona. And then it, I forgot, doesn't do that.
David: That. Would that be something that would make that process easier for you
David: to be able to type that in.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It would, because
VHAALTLEMKEC: you can see how many there are.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And if you know, like we have Wilkes bear.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I have to go through, you know it's quicker for me to tell type in wil.
David: Yeah, to.
VHAALTLEMKEC: To scroll the line.
David: Do you find yourself
David: going in? Besides the Altoona and the Wilkes bear one?
David: Do you go into many other.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, we we have a catchment of 5 Cbocs.
David: So you have 5. Okay?
David: And then what about rest?
David: The ones in? I.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Don't even. I don't even see those. Those aren't. Those don't belong to me.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, okay, well.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Alaska, I don't have to worry about Albany. I don't have to worry about. None of those
VHAALTLEMKEC: have anything to do with me whatsoever.
David: Got it. And how do you feel about seeing all those options.
VHAALTLEMKEC: They're basically in my way.
David: They're in your way.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, I mean, if if, since I'm logged in under my login
VHAALTLEMKEC: and I can only edit
VHAALTLEMKEC: Altoona.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I don't. I don't feel I really need to see Birmingham.
David: Yeah, could you do me a favor on the right section? There's something that says section. And could you open that? Could you expand that option? Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That one's only Altoona health care.
David: So that's the only one you can work in.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That's the only one I can work in.
David: Okay.
David: thank you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: No problem.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So then, when we save
VHAALTLEMKEC: okay, so now that we've saved it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: We can preview.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and you'll see
VHAALTLEMKEC: the barracks cut apart.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and that's how you. That's how you know it's cut.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So then I have to go
VHAALTLEMKEC: back to the page. I have to edit it, and, you know, modify, and since it takes the server about an hour to load.
VHAALTLEMKEC: so I put this together. It won't be live on my page until
VHAALTLEMKEC: probably an hour from now.
David: So ex. Explain to me what happened. How does that get into in the way of your workflow? Do you have to wait an hour to re upload it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, no, I can. I can edit and re upload it right now.
VHAALTLEMKEC: but it until and then it will go live in the order. It's been uploaded, so
VHAALTLEMKEC: it'll
VHAALTLEMKEC: let's say it usually takes about an hour.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So if I edited it if I put it together
VHAALTLEMKEC: 1, 30,
VHAALTLEMKEC: and I found out. It's gonna be, you know, oop, I need to fix something.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Then I re I go back in, edit it and re upload it it. And it's 6, you know. It's 1, 35. It's now going to go live. 5 min later.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It'll always take the latest timestamp.
David: Got it? Got it?
David: Well, okay, how was that experience for you in general? That whole process of uploading the image.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, the process is easy, like, I said. The only the only thing I run into is
VHAALTLEMKEC: decoding in my dyslexic little head, the ratios versus pixels, so.
David: Got it. Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And that's really my biggest issue with the with with the system is, I would prefer
VHAALTLEMKEC: a pixel, a pixel, or measurement
VHAALTLEMKEC: over ratio listings.
David: Got it. So I'm gonna let's move on to our next tab. Here. I'm gonna share with you a link on chat
David: of a prototype.
David: Nope, let's
David: usually.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Let me!
David: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Go ahead and delete the
VHAALTLEMKEC: oh, yes, the one we just put up before it goes flying.
David: Yeah, and I appreciate you. Just kind of.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Not a problem.
David: Going through that process. I.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Edit.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh.
VHAALTLEMKEC: okay, there's a there's something we could run into. It's not easy to delete a page.
David: It's not easy to delete a page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I usually don't have to delete one. So that's kind of weird
VHAALTLEMKEC: enrollment fair.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Just edit
VHAALTLEMKEC: saved.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Huh?
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay?
VHAALTLEMKEC: So we got that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, I can leave it locked for a little while, so I'll have to
VHAALTLEMKEC: figure out Delete
VHAALTLEMKEC: later on, so we can get back to the go back, go back to what we were doing.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: If I leave it, if I leave it locked, it won't publish.
David: Okay. So I just shared with you a big Mo link. If you could open it and share your screen, that would be fantastic.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay, to let me share up chat, chat. Okay?
David: Great! Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Alrighty!
David: Alrighty. So
David: here is a prototype, and it's a potential redesign of the image upload system. It's for events.
David: And I'd like you to imagine that you've started to create a new event for veterans
David: you've entered in the date
David: and which Va location? The event will be listed at
David: now it's time to upload the image.
David: so please show me how you would do that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay. So if it's 1 of our events, I would made already have a graphic available. So I would go ahead, hit upload image.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Then I would select the image I wanted to use.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Use that one.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and oh, that's pretty well framed up, that's good.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and continue
VHAALTLEMKEC: so
VHAALTLEMKEC: there!
VHAALTLEMKEC: I like that
VHAALTLEMKEC: I like.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I like. I like the the recommended image size and file size. That is wonderful right there.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because then, if if I'm not in, if I wanted this to be adjusted. I could run into Photoshop in a minute.
VHAALTLEMKEC: readjust it and take care of that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and then we would enter our alternative text
VHAALTLEMKEC: and.
David: Oh, yeah, if you just click there, it should fill it out. It won't automatically fill like that. But
David: yeah, just to kind of simulate.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Gotcha
VHAALTLEMKEC: perfect.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay? Section
VHAALTLEMKEC: and save and upload.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, that's nice and easy.
David: That's nice and easy. What about it? Makes it nice and easy.
David: Well.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Step by step. It's
VHAALTLEMKEC: number one I know the size that I have to deal with.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So that's the 1st thing that's good.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It gave me the option. It went right.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I'm assuming this is set up to go directly to one of your image folders.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So
VHAALTLEMKEC: hope I lost your audio, brother.
David: Yes, yes, it would go. It would open up the same way that you would have open.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So
VHAALTLEMKEC: if I if cause I usually for
VHAALTLEMKEC: events, I have a a standard image folder I use.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So all my images go into this events folder, and usually when I open, when I
VHAALTLEMKEC: click on upload, it just opens that events folder.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So my graphics are already there.
David: Your graphics are.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I did.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I did like the option that that it had a button right next to it
VHAALTLEMKEC: to search the
VHAALTLEMKEC: like, or the library.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Or the so
VHAALTLEMKEC: usually I don't even think of that until after I've uploaded the image. And I'm actually in the content library.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So that's that's a good
VHAALTLEMKEC: addition. I like that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So yeah, that's I like. And I also like the
VHAALTLEMKEC: instant remove. That's good, too.
VHAALTLEMKEC: in case we need to change it up real quick.
David: Yeah. So say, you notice that it wasn't cropped exactly how you'd like it.
David: What would you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, I would just. I would pull the file.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Then I would
VHAALTLEMKEC: probably reopen it in Photoshop, adjust the image, and then re upload it.
David: Okay. And when you would be uploading it. So I'm curious. Just like how Photoshop works. You would. You would make your adjustments in Photoshop, you would bring it in here.
David: and then the frame would just kind of
David: match. What you're being what you're uploading
David: is that how.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay? So
VHAALTLEMKEC: if we upload the image.
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah. And I see, this frame is this like, here.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I know that
VHAALTLEMKEC: I want.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I would like more of the lamp.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I want it higher.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I want more space between their heads and the top of the bar type thing.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I would go back into my image and adjust it. So the fret. The image stopped
VHAALTLEMKEC: right along this line
VHAALTLEMKEC: and stopped along this line.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Would force this to fill
VHAALTLEMKEC: this square with the image I want.
David: Got it. Got it. So yeah, the image you'd be uploading wouldn't need cropping.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Right.
David: Got it. Yeah.
David: Is it helpful to have the cropping
David: built in.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yes, when when I have an image that
VHAALTLEMKEC: neat that
VHAALTLEMKEC: can be adjusted for cropping.
VHAALTLEMKEC: it does help. So, you know, if we were doing
VHAALTLEMKEC: like a gradient swirl, just pretty colors swooping across the page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That would be great because I could move the picture around and go right there. It's good.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know that sort of thing cause those are usually, you know, huge.
VHAALTLEMKEC: They're designed to be enormously big and crappable. So
VHAALTLEMKEC: that's what this would be great is great for.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But when you have a set image that is a specific size, a specific design.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you generally have to make sure you know what your banner size is going to be before you upload the image.
David: Hmm!
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So.
VHAALTLEMKEC: having this
VHAALTLEMKEC: this event, image recommended premium, you know that sort of thing.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, let's there we go! There we go.
VHAALTLEMKEC: having that
VHAALTLEMKEC: here
VHAALTLEMKEC: in the event. Image box.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Better.
David: Before you're
David: while you're preparing your image, you have that information.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Exactly.
David: Got it, got it? Okay, so it could be moved out.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah. So if it said, event image recommended size, you know x or
VHAALTLEMKEC: x pixels by y pixels
VHAALTLEMKEC: no more than 10 MB. Jpeg, gif png
VHAALTLEMKEC: right here.
VHAALTLEMKEC: or actually, you know, like, in this box where the photo is, you could have it. And then when you upload the photo, it's just gone, but that would be perfect.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That would be.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That would be. I'd get to this point and go.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Crud! Is that it? Yep, that image is good to go, you know, because I usually have Photoshop open with the image I've been editing. Still, there.
David: Got it. Got it? Got it?
David: Okay, yeah, thank you so much for sharing that. Let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: No no problem.
David: If you go ahead and click X, and let's walk through that process one more time. Over the image. Sorry. There's a lot of X's on the screen.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Right? Right? And I'm sorry. Yeah, I was like, okay.
David: So
David: here we have upload image. Let's go ahead and click on that one again.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Dry.
David: I'm curious about a couple of things. 1st off.
David: One thing that's no longer here, and I'm not sure if you noticed it
David: is, that description is no longer here.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, okay. I thought something was missing. I just didn't catch what was missing.
David: So what what do you think about that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That doesn't bother me in the least.
David: That doesn't bother you in the least. That description.
VHAALTLEMKEC: No, no, because
VHAALTLEMKEC: if people are smart
VHAALTLEMKEC: which I really wish they would be the file name
VHAALTLEMKEC: is going to tell me generally what the picture is, and the alternative text is going to generally tell me what the picture is.
David: So the combination of the 2 is sufficient.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Usually. Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, unless you get people who like to upload.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Img underscore 0 0 1, 2, 6, 4, 2, 3 dot jpeg, you know, like, Oh, come on! Couldn't you take 2 seconds to name the photo?
David: Yeah, I see that I've been guilty of that in my past.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, we all we all have, which is also another reason. I don't hunt through the
VHAALTLEMKEC: media library because there are a lot of people that do upload
VHAALTLEMKEC: that.
David: Oh, interesting. So yeah, we can talk about that in a second. The media library.
David: I'm also curious. One other thing that has been removed. Here is the. There's like there used to be a button in there.
David: a little checkmark that says, this image can be reusable for the media library.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, that's I'm good with that being removed because
VHAALTLEMKEC: I assumed anything that went into the media library was going to be reused because it belongs to Va. National, anyway.
David: Got it. Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: You. You most likely. You know Birmingham is not going to use a file of our director giving an award to one of our nurses.
David: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Do fine, you know. It's not like it's.
David: They do. It's fine. They probably won't.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Exactly
VHAALTLEMKEC: because they're gonna have.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It's it's very rare that you know, different
VHAALTLEMKEC: facilities need images from the other facility.
VHAALTLEMKEC: because most of the stuff we're putting out is
VHAALTLEMKEC: directly related to the facility we're in.
David: So. I'm curious when you upload images and you're using your media library. It's typically
David: only images. You only really care about the images that you have uploaded.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah. It's very rare that I need anything else from
VHAALTLEMKEC: anywhere else.
David: And what about your beyond you? What about like other people who are working with Altoona?
David: When do you ever use it?
VHAALTLEMKEC: I I am. I am the Altoona Guy.
David: Okay, got it. So no, you're not looking to other
David: people in your section for those images. It's it's you.
David: So.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah. Well, like the images that come are are sent to me from my facility.
VHAALTLEMKEC: There's something
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah. So like, we have a
VHAALTLEMKEC: oh, 10 year, or nurses getting a 10 year recognition PIN, and you know for that they'll send me a picture of, you know, my director giving that, you know, congratulating nurse so and so, and giving her her full.
VHAALTLEMKEC: her PIN and her.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, plaque and stuff.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And then that will be. That will probably be a news story. We post.
David: And what about recurring events or things like that, where you need the same.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Same ground. Oh, same.
VHAALTLEMKEC: we really don't have a lot of occur reoccurring events. We.
VHAALTLEMKEC: our our facility tries to theme things.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So when we have a recruitment fair or an you know,
VHAALTLEMKEC: enrollment fare.
VHAALTLEMKEC: We're going to have like fall enrollment, and you know they'll have a theme, for you know, because we're going to hold it at the
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know the Altoona Curve baseball
VHAALTLEMKEC: diamond. So you know it'll be baseball and fall themed.
VHAALTLEMKEC: The next one will be
VHAALTLEMKEC: at the fun run that happens every year, and you know spring or whatever so.
David: Right?
David: Okay. So reuse is not as common. You are
David: the only person who's using it.
David: I see.
David: Okay, fantastic.
David: and let's see here.
David: I think the file name is the same. The Alt text is the same per section.
David: One thing I'm curious about it's not really shown here. But ideally, it this version could have. It is really just focusing on the sections that you're part of.
David: or even considering the section that
David: you input right before, where the event will be listed in.
David: Would that be something.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Be perfect.
David: For you.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah, if it was just the department, it well and mainly because once again, I can't post to anyone else's stuff.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So you know, seeing, you know, for lack of a term. Birmingham again.
David: Yeah, Birmingham.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Is it going to make a difference? Because I select Birming. If I accidentally select Birmingham.
VHAALTLEMKEC: it's just gonna give me an error message going. You can't upload this.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But I gotta go back and they go. Okay. I'll tuna, you know.
David: Afternoon. So if the section only had the sections you could work in that would be beneficial for you. Yep.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Or if it preloaded them.
David: Or preloaded them. Yeah. Got got it?
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because.
David: You were. What if you were part of multiple sections.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Well, that's okay. So that's that's a good point. Because we do have 5 different Cbocs. But a lot of times our events are held at different
VHAALTLEMKEC: times for each Cboc.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So we would. Ha! I'd have to make a different event for each one.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So, for example, we just had an enrollment fair at James E. Van Zant.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Well, not an aroma for a drive through flu clinic last Saturday.
VHAALTLEMKEC: but
VHAALTLEMKEC: our State college
VHAALTLEMKEC: Cboc, is having the exact same event.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But it's this Saturday.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So I'm using there. There's a point where I would. You reuse the logo.
David: I see what you're saying.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I've already made the drive through Logo, so I'm just going to use it for each one of the Cboc's.
David: Got it. Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because they're just all the same exact event. They're just on different dates and times.
David: Different dates and times.
David: Yeah.
David: So my other question for you is
David: there on the original one that you've gone through. You had 2 options at the end of including all the Alt text section. That kind of thing there was, save and insert
David: and save and select.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah.
VHAALTLEMKEC: say I, I
VHAALTLEMKEC: always say I always save in it, or which whichever one automatically loads it.
David: The one that you click, and then the images on your page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Right
VHAALTLEMKEC: cause.
VHAALTLEMKEC: If I need to go to the media library, I can go to the media library, but most of the time I know the image that I'm working with, and I just need to get it up. So there's no reason to
VHAALTLEMKEC: save and select. Be brought to the media library, where it shows me that I've checked off the photo that I've already been working on and then upload, you know. So the whole idea of save and upload is just fine.
David: And upload is fine. Ha, yeah, okay.
David: okay. Great. Great.
David: Okay. Well, I have a couple last questions for you as we're wrapping up.
David: and I think you you touched on this a bit
David: beyond
David: events and image uploading.
David: Are there any other aspects of drupal cms that could
David: be made a little bit easier, or cause you a little bit more frustration than you'd like them to.
VHAALTLEMKEC: There's a couple of things for example, if I may.
David: Yeah. Please show me whatever is easiest.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So I just remembered
VHAALTLEMKEC: enrollment fair
VHAALTLEMKEC: how you get rid of a page.
David: Yeah. Deleting a page, we heard that one was.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So you have to go back down here
VHAALTLEMKEC: and archive.
David: You have to archive it. Okay, yep.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And now it's gone.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Once it saves
VHAALTLEMKEC: provided takes. There we go. Now it's
VHAALTLEMKEC: now it's gone. It's archived, it's off my screen.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Got it. So we're good there. The other thing is.
VHAALTLEMKEC: when we are a lot of my groups want
VHAALTLEMKEC: what we call informational pages or
VHAALTLEMKEC: more detail, but
VHAALTLEMKEC: they're not qualified as detail pages for some reason.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So for health services.
VHAALTLEMKEC: women's health.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So we got our link here to women's health.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Okay? So this is all the information
VHAALTLEMKEC: they wanted and see like, this is the long list that could have been broken into 2 groups if you wanted
VHAALTLEMKEC: But
VHAALTLEMKEC: and they're gonna they have more to add.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But you notice where it's showing up over here.
David: Programs.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Right
VHAALTLEMKEC: it shouldn't be there. But the only way I've got to go back in and clean it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: because the only way to add content like that
VHAALTLEMKEC: is, I can go to Vma detail page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah, rich
VHAALTLEMKEC: gives me a detail, but the only place I can parent it to
VHAALTLEMKEC: I can't
VHAALTLEMKEC: not turn off the menu link.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I have to
VHAALTLEMKEC: parent it to something.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and it's only I can't select anything except this down here
VHAALTLEMKEC: programs and below.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So if I want to be able to add links.
VHAALTLEMKEC: have the ability to add extra content like, upload those files and stuff.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It has to be a detail page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: It can't be
VHAALTLEMKEC: hang on a second
VHAALTLEMKEC: if I go to up here.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Media content
VHAALTLEMKEC: health service.
VHAALTLEMKEC: See? We got facility, health service and system health service.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I want to add.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I want to add a health service page.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I don't get all the extra.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I only get to tell them
VHAALTLEMKEC: it belongs to.
VHAALTLEMKEC: you know, gynecology.
VHAALTLEMKEC: And here's the form. Here's the text. I can't link
VHAALTLEMKEC: extra files or anything like that.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So you get very limited allowance for detail pages
VHAALTLEMKEC: for services.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So, for example, if you go to our pharmacy.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Sorry.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Nope, that's not where I want to go. Health services.
VHAALTLEMKEC: We go to
VHAALTLEMKEC: pharmacy.
VHAALTLEMKEC: We have a pharmacy and addition.
VHAALTLEMKEC: but it is literally
VHAALTLEMKEC: oh, no, this one. I actually did
VHAALTLEMKEC: the same upload that I did before. I just haven't. I just cleaned it off the
VHAALTLEMKEC: the other page. Let's see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: we have another one here somewhere.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Nope, I don't think we do, actually.
VHAALTLEMKEC: yeah, no, I think we're just. Those are the few
VHAALTLEMKEC: we've wanted to do a lot of detail pages like the ones I've built, but because there isn't the ability to really add on
VHAALTLEMKEC: without making a bunch of extra work to get it off the programs. Page
VHAALTLEMKEC: people haven't been using it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Does that make sense.
David: The page is not where you so so just to clarify pharmacy is a health service, and you're able to have a link
David: where that pharmacy lives
David: kind of as a trial for health services, but the women's health one you're not able to add in your link.
David: so it won't.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Yeah it
VHAALTLEMKEC: to to use so health services.
VHAALTLEMKEC: we can add links to these little descriptions.
David: Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Guy.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Now.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I built both of these pharmacy and gynecology
VHAALTLEMKEC: on the same style, on the same design pharmacy had, or what used to be under programs as well.
VHAALTLEMKEC: If you clicked on programs you would get it used to be
VHAALTLEMKEC: pharmacy. Daisy Award B. Award.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Because
VHAALTLEMKEC: it has. I have to use that template
VHAALTLEMKEC: to get the ability
VHAALTLEMKEC: to upload
VHAALTLEMKEC: files.
VHAALTLEMKEC: So for health, serve for women's health services.
VHAALTLEMKEC: To be able to add these resources. I have to use the
VHAALTLEMKEC: detail page.
David: Oh, okay, so you would prefer that the facilities, health services
David: have the same
David: complexity and options that detail.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Detail page did exactly.
David: Because you were forced to
David: pick a detail page because you had all these links.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Right, because the more they have more so you have the Facility Health Service.
David: Yes.
VHAALTLEMKEC: When you build it. This is just literally the little bit that pops up
VHAALTLEMKEC: on that dropdown.
David: Right.
VHAALTLEMKEC: You know. So it's that's all that is.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Then
VHAALTLEMKEC: you have
VHAALTLEMKEC: the system health service.
VHAALTLEMKEC: That is what you can make. If you wanted to add a ta, or add a link in the dropdown
VHAALTLEMKEC: to give you more information.
David: And that's where you put those links. These are the.
VHAALTLEMKEC: This is where I would like to put the links, but I don't have the option.
David: I see.
VHAALTLEMKEC: The only option I have is to put in a paragraph, and up to 6 bullet points.
David: Got it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Whereas I would like to be able to create an entire detail page
VHAALTLEMKEC: for that, because when you do build a detail page
VHAALTLEMKEC: or just have this option, added the detail page
VHAALTLEMKEC: you
VHAALTLEMKEC: get to select my Altoona
VHAALTLEMKEC: system.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I get to select Altoona again
VHAALTLEMKEC: down here. It's going to provide a menu link. I can't turn that off.
VHAALTLEMKEC: and I can tell the link, you know.
VHAALTLEMKEC: whatever I wanted to call it.
VHAALTLEMKEC: But the only place I'm allowed to put it, is programs
VHAALTLEMKEC: under under any of the program lines under research
VHAALTLEMKEC: which is disabled
VHAALTLEMKEC: jobs and careers.
VHAALTLEMKEC: volunteer donate or doing business.
VHAALTLEMKEC: I can't put it under health care.
David: Got it. Okay?
David: Well, thank you so much for taking the time to chat with me today. I know we're right at time. I did want to open it up to my Notetaker Observer. If there's any additional questions anyone has
David: feel free to ask them
David: now.
Megan Commons: None from my end.
Megan Commons: Yeah.
Marisa: No, no questions for me either, David. Thank you, Chris, for for your time today.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Oh, I'm happy to do it! Not a problem.
David: Great? Well, and do you have any questions for me as we wrap up.
VHAALTLEMKEC: No, no, actually, this was very productive. I appreciate it.
David: Yeah, it was super productive. Well, we really appreciate you taking the time today to share your thoughts with us. Your feedback is so helpful for making Vagov easier for veterans and editors alike to use. So thank you again, and enjoy the rest of your day.
VHAALTLEMKEC: Alright! Thanks a lot. You, too.